it's mid-june and that means of course
monsoon season is upon us many across
the valley
hoping for substantial rainfall
something we haven't seen
in nearly three years so what can we
expect this summer
orco mana joining us live now on channel
8 with that answer hi orco
hey there brian well monsoon season is
typically from july
to september and during that time we'll
usually see big rainstorms
so big that they fill washes like this
one with
water but in recent years they've stayed
like this
empty and dry experts hope this summer
is different
the national weather service in las
vegas releases a weather balloon while
the technology tracks current conditions
senior forecaster john adair is also
focused on the future
i think most people are hopeful to see
at least some thunderstorms and heavy
rainfall
monsoon season is starting but the past
couple years haven't lived up to the
name with only sprinkles here and there
the last year we had a fairly active
season monsoon season was 2018.
adair says that's because the high
pressure patterns have not been set up
to bring us major moisture
in the summer months we just rely on it
getting pulled up from here
it's still unclear what this year's
monsoon season will look like but we can
expect
issues if there's still little rainfall
the dry vegetation
around our region and all across the
west is
going to make wildfire season probably
quite accurate
also a concern low water levels at lake
mead
i'm quite scared environmental activists
tell me given the conditions we have to
rethink our water consumption
it's been so dry here that in order to
sustain the plant
life that we have in the area we have to
use more of the water
so it's everything conspiring against us
to make this a real emergency as the
summer continues adair is keeping his
eyes
on the skies it's really july that we
start to
see how or the potential of an active
monsoon season now adair adds that is
usually
the first or second week in july that
pretty much indicates what kind of
monsoon
monsoon season we can have and we'll see
if we have any thunderstorms resulting
in that
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now